what up carlos first of all can i say
how fun it is to see a dance movie where
like everybody is such a pro like
everybody is like working it
so to speak it must have been a blast to
shoot wasn't it
no unfortunately no we can't we can't
lie i mean like
you would have been able to tell if we
were not enjoying ourselves on screen we
spent too much time with each other
it really was like one of the best
summers uh we keep saying it
it was one of the best summers of our
life but also to like work on a movie
that doesn't feel like work except for
the amount of sweat that was dripping
off of our bodies by the end of it
um and lack of sleep but like whatever
um it was so
so special and uh i hope i hope other
people feel the same way we do about it
we're just really genuinely excited
yeah it's it's in that vein of like the
high school dance movie and there's so
many great ones
uh liza you gotta tell me because you're
like
you really give it like you're really
working it in this movie
improvise a lot of your moves or is that
all choreography
oh lord okay so it's hard for the heart
for this one to stick the script and
you'll see because i'm gonna keep
talking right now
um but i did i i improvised really good
lines a little bit here and there but i
also improvised a little bit of
choreography because they were like can
you do a flip and i was like no but i
can't do this split
uh can you do uh maybe a turn i was like
no but i can't do this split
so i do do the flip about did a split
about uh four times throughout the
course of this film that is my
one trick pony that uh never gets old
hopefully but um
i don't know fun it was fun our our
amazing choreographers ahmad and amy
allen shout out to them they
they did such a wonderful job at
highlighting every person's like
you know strength and and really
connecting all those together to make
one really strong unit
so yeah yeah it's cool in the story you
know
quinn is sort of discovering that she
kind of maybe wants her life to move in
a different direction who's going
i mean you guys have both been doing
what you're doing for such a long time
but i wonder
if there was ever a time that you can
remember when you were younger that
you wanted to do something other than
what you're doing right now you sabrina
could start with you oh when i was
younger
i mean i think like from a very very
small window of like age two to three
like i
i'd contemplated being a drummer and
then i realized i was like
no i was like i can make sounds with
another instrument and that
ended up being my voice i guess um but i
really
i i can happily say that this is kind of
always what i wanted to do and it hasn't
really changed over the course of time
it's definitely
i've been met with some more
difficulties through throughout the
years and
um and things that you know i've had to
face
that i didn't think i would have to when
i first initially
wanted to i guess enter this world but
just entertainment in general like i
love making people feel good and i love
i love how it makes me feel good so i
think it's just like those positive
uh vibes and energy that that kind of
radiate through these different projects
whether that be music or movies
um has always kind of stuck with me i'm
always reminding myself like why did i
want to start doing this oh yes i love
it you know what i mean
it makes me feel really happy yeah eyes
what about you
i would say that's like a quote i live
by like when things are getting tough
remind yourself of the reason
you got started or when you feel like
giving up i probably said that because
you reminded me
to think like that yeah i think i saw
you post that
and i was like oh liza i've worked with
her she's cool
yeah you know i love being a role model
for the youth um
so i think i think time that i like
contemplated like or wanted to
you know step into a new career path of
sorts i would say was about a year ago
prior to filming work it um when i was
younger
uh i that was like me this is a feels
like a really
cool moment for me and my career and
transitioning into
a more traditional space and and you
know dancing
in a movie which has always been a huge
huge dream of mine so i'm so thankful to
be a part of this um
but going from like online content
creator and you know executive producer
of my own
you know shows and snippets to you know
coming onto a set where i'm working for
a nice ep
right there in pink you're looking at
her that's my boss
um my boy
she keeps appointed um but yeah it was
amazing to walk onto set and and you
know trust the people
around me and just go in and literally
dance and just have fun
so it's really cool i'm happy to say
that this is a digital path that i took
but
um anybody else could take it too if
they want to so yeah that's amazing well
thanks so much for your time youtube
a pleasure chatting with you pleasure
watching you guys dance it up see ya
canada this was shot in toronto yeah but